[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero conocido
como el último dictador de europa
alexander lukashenko se ha convertido
desde agosto de 2020 en uno de los
mayores dolores de cabeza para la unión
europea pero quién es este controvertido
político y por qué es importante de la
luz para el bloque europeo belarús es
una nación que históricamente ha sido
puente de unión entre rusia y europa
occidental además es un punto clave de
paso para gaseoductos que tienen como
destino el corazón del continente
europeo la unión entre rusia y belarús
siempre ha sido muy fuerte ya que esta
nación perteneció durante siglos a rusia
pero en 1991 tras la disolución de la
unión soviética se conformó una nueva
república que de forma temprana pasó al
poder de alexander lukashenko este
mandatario de orígenes humildes es hijo
político de la unión soviética y se
postuló desde un principio en la defensa
del ala más conservadora del partido
comunista de la extinta nación y en
contra de la perestroika lanzada por
mijail gorbachov para abrir
políticamente al país socialista su
figura empezó a cobrar relevancia tres
años después de las de belarús del resto
de la urss cuando se presentó como
candidato en las primeras elecciones
libres en la historia del país con dos
puntos clave como ejes de su campaña la
lucha contra la corrupción y la
nostalgia hacia lo que representaba la
unión soviética
lo más importante ahora es establecer un
orden firme en el país y combatir el
crimen y la corrupción me molesta que el
gabinete y los ministros hayan amenazado
con dimitir
pero su fortaleza en belarús no se puede
entender sin el apoyo determinante que
siempre ha ejercido moscú su alianza con
rusia se fraguó durante el gobierno de
boris yeltsin y ha perdurado en la era
de vladimir putin lukashenko ha
priorizado el uso del ruso en belarús y
el acercamiento hacia el kremlin con el
objetivo de alejarse de lo que
consideraba la amenaza extranjera
occidental salvo puntuales desencuentros
durante el gobierno de putin rusia ha
ofrecido a belarús un apoyo económico y
militar fundamental que ha ayudado a
lukashenko a perpetuarse en el poder
hasta el momento algo importante ya que
desde principios de la década de los
2000 comenzaron a resonar las primeras
voces de alarma con respecto a lo que se
estaba convirtiendo belarús en 2001 se
dieron las primeras elecciones
consideradas por la comunidad
internacional como manipuladas
lukashenko obtuvo el 75% de los votos y
su poder siguió consolidándose con la
eliminación del límite de mandatos en
2004 que le permitió ser reelegido en
2006 con el 83% de los votos resultados
que el mandatario bielorruso siempre
defendió
no es la primera vez que me enfrento al
hecho de que occidente esté preocupado
he estado trabajando durante 10 años y
ustedes están preocupados durante 10
años con algo
deberían calmarse y dejar de acusarnos
de violaciones y falsificaciones yo creo
que tienen muchos problemas similares
al fraude se sumaron las denuncias de
represión a opositores numerosos
organizaciones y activistas intentaron
desde los primeros años del siglo 21
apartar del poder a lukashenko sin éxito
las victorias del mandatario bielorruso
fueron aún más antes para las elecciones
de 2010 y 2015 donde un número
importante de los candidatos rivales
fueron perseguidos encarcelados o
tuvieron que marchar al exilio pero a
pesar de la controversia sus acciones
represivas pasaban relativamente
desapercibidas en el panorama
internacional
esto cambió en agosto de 2020 la
oposición acudió a los comicios
organizada en torno a la figura de
esveld a nati cano pesca ya la última de
todos los candidatos opositores que no
había sido encarcelada y demostró su
fuerza en la calle lukashenko volvió a
hacerse con la victoria pero el fraude
fue muy evidente ante la opinión pública
algo que desató unas protestas
históricas en todo el país que hicieron
por primera vez sentido amenazado al
mandatario esto ocasionó que la
represión aumentara y que miles de
personas fueran detenidas durante todas
las manifestaciones las cifras hablan
por sí mismas se estima que más de
20.000 manifestantes fueron arrestados
por las autoridades en los primeros
meses de protestas detenciones que en
muchas ocasiones fueron acompañadas de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
torturas y vejaciones que fueron
denunciadas por la organización mundial
contra la tortura o naciones unidas para
el gobierno de lukashenko sin embargo
todo se trataba de injerencias
extranjeras que atacaban su soberanía
una respuesta que originó que la unión
europea y eeuu emitieran las primeras
sanciones contra este país y aumentarán
su aislamiento internacional
estas son las acciones de grupos
delictivos organizados con signos de
terrorismo estamos comenzando a
enfrentar amenazas terroristas
ya no es una guerra de información sino
una guerra terrorista que se lanza
contra nosotros en direcciones separadas
debemos detener esta crisis pero
lukashenko continuó en el poder y ahora
la unión europea lo acusa de orquestar y
dirigir una ola migratoria de miles de
personas de áfrica y medio oriente para
desestabilizar sus fronteras un golpe
directo a una de las mayores debilidades
de bruselas que se suma a la amenaza de
cortar el suministro de gas proveniente
de rusia en un momento de crisis
energética y aumento de precios gestos
que meten presión sobre europa y que
tienen el objetivo de poner fin al
descrédito internacional y el órdago de
sanciones que recae sobre minsk
así concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]